pods are no longer the stuff of science
fiction these capsule like structures
can be well downright claustrophobic for
some but pod possibilities are
multiplying what are these pods like and
why do we want to get in them let's take
a look
while Elon Musk proposed Hyperloop gets
all the attention there were already
modern-day transportation pods up and
running one in London's Heathrow Airport
the other in Abu Dhabi Masdar City I
need to do anything it is moving these
futuristic PR teas or personal rapid
transport systems are electric
driverless egg-shaped cars that see
anywhere from two to four people the
benefit that is not as Posh as public
transportation yes
you just plug in your destination and
off you go the latest PRTs are powered
by onboard batteries and are guided by
GPS but they're pricey hiepro system
cost more than forty five million
dollars to develop despite the price
point you'll soon be seeing more of them
another in England one in India and an
aerial version in Israel
Tod's are also taking to the high fees a
design permanent italy has created the
jet capsule it's a 25 foot long 11 foot
wide poly on that fits 8 the opening
price tag is 250 thousand dollars these
jeans during a layover hotel is one of
the airport pod pioneers you can rent
one of the rooms of Heathrow for a
little over a hundred dollars for the
night or for about 50 bucks for four
hours and occupancy rates have soared
over two hundred and fifty percent now
other companies are trying to cash in on
the trend in Alva Davi you can occupy a
ghostly pod or if in Munich nap cab
offers a respite from the terminal so
let's be straight many of these pods
don't offer much more than a bed a bed
that can kind of feel like a coffin
you're not fitting to pees in that pod